hi guys Lucy here with another gamespot
news update for you the great ship
destiny has sprung yet another leak with
a whole host of data and images hitting
the web apparently detailing the brand
new expansion house of wolves one
anonymous Japanese player has managed to
access vast portions of the new update
via the existing game files and it
posted all of the findings on reddit key
details uncovered include thorough
descriptions of missions as well as
images of new weapons armor and
expansion scheduled release date which
will apparently fall on Tuesday the 19th
of May according to the dated expansion
appears to take place on the moon level
and is set to offer a new awoken
storyline plus an exclusive raid three
new crucible maps a new foreign strike
and hundreds of new weapons armor and
gear meanwhile Bungie community manager
David dig has addressed the leak on the
official destiny forum asking fans to
bear in mind that aside from giving in a
name Bungie has yet to reveal the house
of wolves that means that anything you
know about it can change we have a team
working on the experience in our own
fancy room and they have some exciting
surprises up their sleeves we reserve
the right to overwrite anything you're
looking at right now these placeholder
items enable us to see room on your
drive for actual future update you'll
all download them before it's time to
play any stats or assumptions about
power or impact or handsomeness our
month old and do not reflect the things
that we're doing to adapt to what you've
taught us about destiny there is a
process here and you're a part of it all
we ask is that you leave your mind open
to the evolution that are inevitable
what you see here are very old ghosts
from our pre-launch database these are
not necessarily the wolves you're
looking for so what do you make of it
all are you still interested in destiny
do you have your own fancy room which
you work on experiences in for all the
latest on house of wolves make sure to
stay tuned to gamespot com
you